doxa bo can you tell us how important is
it to share this beautiful way of life
Dawa and also to support the Dawa these
efforts of people who are out there
trying to really communicate this
message of the Dean of Islam miss Molloy
rahmani raheem it's very important if
you are doing Dawa we have to find out
why we are doing it very important Allah
Subhan o Allah says in the quran surah
16 higher number 125 or the OLS abelia
Rebecca bill hickmott even more as I
tell Hassan ativa jardel humidity here
as an invite all to the way of Allah
with wisdom and good preaching and
converse with them in ways which are
best and most gracious we are doing Dawa
inviting humanity to Islam inviting
humanity to the worship of the Creator
inviting humanity to paradise so we do
dava because it is an obligation we do
dava because we love humanity we are
concerned for Humanity we want the best
for Humanity so that is reason enough
but the second important reason is
misconceptions about Islam they're
increasing day in and day out according
to the Pew Research Foundation survey
marsh 2015 only twenty-one percent of
the population in this country they have
a positive perception about Islam and
that percentage is going down is single
year unfortunately if misconceptions are
increasing people are not aware about
who Allah subhanAllah what's the purpose
of life it is you and me we have the
obligation of showing to them who is the
creator what's the purpose of life and
to reduce the misconceptions if
misconception is the wall between them
and thao he'd that means we should
remove the wall and show them the beauty
of Islam you know two years ago when i
was living in an apartment when the snow
was there in the winter season i found
out that my neighbor's car is parked the
wrong side of the road and I was afraid
that the $25 ticket would be given to
him if it does not move the car I became
concerned for him I picked up my phone I
call him so he could save that $25 how
about people who are heading towards
health
fire by worshipping humans worshipping
idols worshipping the creation if you
are concerned for $25 should we not be
concerned for them living eternity in
the Hellfire so for any and all of these
reasons my dear Muslims and my dear
people of good heart and good faith we
should come together not only do Dawa
but support dava especially the Dean
show which is out there in the front
line conveying the message it needs lots
of resources the cameras that you see up
there you know the Lightning appeared
the editing that we do the scholars that
he calls all of them the required they
all they need not just the time but
expenses how much is spent actually it's
a shame you know when you look at people
I believe last so much it was over a
hundred million dollars has been spent
to distort Islam to attack Islam yeah
we're asking people how much are you
spending to share Islam 159 million how
much that well 159 million yes but all
of these hate groups which are out there
but Pamela Geller and Steve Emerson and
Robert Spencer all of these groups and
many many more they are collecting money
and fear-mongering and trying to despair
a discredit Islam if they could do that
much for hate campaign and not just them
by the way Christian missionaries in
this country they create 53,000
full-time Christian missionaries each
single year in this country and they
send it out to the Muslim countries
they're all they're all they're spending
big money yeah not only they're
dedicating their life they're spending
big money all in the or for the sake for
the purpose of sharing Trinity sharing
[ __ ] but Muslims you and me we are the
custodians of haha a las bonnet Allah
has blessed us but this blessing is not
just for you and me as a las bonnet
Allah says in the quran surah Baqarah 2
ayah number 185 shahru ramadan led UN
Salafi Hill Quran Hodel in nasa bahay
anatomy nerja dhaval for horn you know
this is the month of ramadan and we all
read the Quran be listened to the Quran
but a la sabana thought I saying that in
the month of Ramadan the Quran was
revealed as a guidance to all of
humanity as a guidance to all of
humanity and is a criteria to
distinguish between right and wrong so
we are not the custodians of the Quran
the Quran belongs to humanity and you
and me are the ones to take this Quran
it's message is beauty its guidance to
all of humanity and last but not the
least this is a critical time here in
crisis that if you don't go out and
convey the message we don't want our
children holding us responsible that you
know dad father abu ji when you had the
opportunity when you had the ability
when you had the resources why didn't
you go out and conveyed the message why
didn't you like flood the whole world
with the mute beauty the message the
guidance of islam why did you left us
left us with the world in which there
are restrictions we cannot practice the
faith they're all the laws against the
Muslims against Islam it would be a very
very sad situation if our kids are going
to say that to us to our generation and
that's not it by the way what if you are
in our death beds and we regret that
2016 when the fear-mongering was going
on Islamophobia was rampant why didn't
we do more we would be having a sad day
on our dead bed not our death but forget
about that what about on the day of
judgment when a las manadas going to
question as why didn't you do more when
he had the time when you are building
the massages even though we need the
massages when you had the ability the
resources why didn't you do more for the
sake of Islam inviting humanity to peace
we cannot come back on the day back on
earth and do the things that peak we
should be doing now so for any and all
of those things it's an obligation to
share the wonderful message it's a
necessity because of the situation and
for all of these things to share the
message and to and to do the production
of these shows and to print the
brochures and to have the social media
channels money is needed resources are
needed so the Muslim Ummah is very
generous they understand that this is
the best way to convey the message
which we always speak about Islamophobia
the best way to tackle Islamophobia is
to educate the people not just by good
words by good actions and when you
support inshallah not only the people
who are in the front line they could do
Dawa the reward will also come to you
inshallah so I hope and pray that not
only we do we so I hope and pray to
Allah Subhan Allah that he make it easy
for us he gives us the toffee the
motivation the inspiration that all of
us united as one Muslim Ummah under the
banner of la illaha illallah muhammadur
rasulullah we become peace ambassadors
of islam to humanity Allah help us and
motivate us to spend that money on good
causes because it's going to stay behind
and now as they spend the millions to
bash Islam to attack Islam will you
spend something to share share to help
share Islam you make that decision if so
contribute now Salam alaikum peace be
with you